jérémy a travaillé tout l'été pour une
petite entreprise de peinture à domicile
il en a peint des portes des fenêtres
des murs et des clôtures
c'est l'entreprise qui évalue est la
durée des travaux
elle payait jérémy seulement pour le
nombre d'heures évalué autour du salaire
minimum 11 dollars 25 l'heure mais les
travaux durent est toujours plus
longtemps que ce que l'entreprise avait
prévu jérémy avait beau travailler
d'arrache-pied
il ne terminais jamais à temps il a
travaillé pendant 160 heures cet été
mais l'entreprise lui a payé seulement
110 heures il a donc été payés bien en
dessous du salaire minimum est ce légal
non même si une entreprise boupère
contrat elle ne peut vous donner moins
que le salaire minimum
jérémy peut donc porter plainte à
l'organisme qui surveille le marché du
travail
la cnss t le fin mot de l'histoire
le salaire minimum c'est vraiment un
minimum
[Applaudissements]